the Joe Rogan experience don't worry
like I'm like an attorney trying to
interrogate you but I feel like I spent
a lot of time digging into research I
had the research checked in checked and
checked again I had the research check
to make sure that it was not
cherry-picking that it was reflective of
the preponderance of evidence but who
was checking it were they people who
were not advocates of a whole food
plant-based diet exclusively or were
they example like because all of the
experts in the film are people who are
clearly aligned with this that person
interview them because they're aligned
with the consensus and no on an over
half of I thought you just agreed that
there is not a consensus that 100%
plant-based diet is better than a diet
that includes a lot of plans for what
some animal products so so where were
the experts that would represent that
point of view plant-based diet doesn't
have to be a hundred percent the film's
had plant-based diet now I'll tell you
why we only interviewed vegans over the
athletes right the ones that actually
spoke on screen in Arnold is not vegan
he doesn't drink dairy things it's for
babies and he's cut down meat by 80% but
all the people I mean you know nate is
not a hundred percent vegan
he's on a largely plant-based diet eats
a bit of seafood and bitter stuff like
that but all these yeah eggs as well so
all the reason that we only put and by
the way we did interview Loren Cordain
and Rob wolf and I can get to that as
well if you want because the
anthropologist laughed in their faces
claims that you know where I'm talking
about scientists who published Sandy's
but you know who are on the team Dyess
the papers that I've shared yeah it's
like new tracks who are funded by the
industry and we can get no not new true
it's disingenuous to claim that all of
the research that that I've shared is
industry do you want to we can't ignore
your claim that like you know the recent
study that just came out and we were
getting off track the recent study that
just came out that said that red meat
and processed meat is totally fine right
like you really want to go with that but
to me it feels like you don't have your
finger on the pulse honestly I'm not
trying to be rude I think you probably
know a lot about yourself about that
study well in the Nutri wreck study
the study that said that ready there's a
new Trek study okay so in the annals of
internal medicine the day before the
film came out six studies exonerating
red meat and processed meat all from the
same company that apparently giving
recommendations well guess what exponent
and nutria Rex and companies like that
are not the ones that give public
recommendations on what people should be
eating number one okay and we talked
about this in the film with exponent
nutria Rex is like another exponent so
if you look at their recommendations
first of all Frank who Frank who is now
the chair of nutrition Harvard he took
what will its place said the panels
bring your recommendations that adults
should continue to their red meat
consumption habits is highly
irresponsible Walter Willett said it's
the most egregious abuse of data he's
ever seen and if you want to follow
their recommendations if you could put
up slide 92 so they did the same thing
in 2017 for the sugar industry so there
was a meta-analysis in the annals any
state they you mean the nutria same so
it was so Bradley Johnston is the
director and co-founder of nutria rates
and the first author of the paper that
we're talking about for red meat okay
that just exonerated red meat apparently
and processed me so this is the same
company says that the president there
seems to be no reliable evidence
indicating that any of the recommended
daily caloric thresholds for sugar
intake are strongly associated with
negative health effects so there you get
a meta-analysis saying that don't worry
about your intake of sugar at all
that was what their meta-analysis the
collusion it came to and then two years
later the day before the kallmes kept
film came out and do you really think
that's a coincidence do you think that
the so let me tell you something okay
the of our email subscribers do you know
the email address of the person that
opens and views our emails the most from
the beef checkoff program and they've
been doing that since we started
so they sign up for our mailing list
they look at when the film is coming out
and you don't you think it's a
coincidence that the day before us the
film comes out they release a paper
exonerating red meat and cancer and the
same say so if you're gonna buy into the
neutral rec study about red meat and
cancer then to be fair you've also got
to buy in
their conclusions about sugar because
they were paid I'll tell you who they
were paid by okay so so the financial
support for that paper was funded by the
technical it's caught this now listen to
this sounds great the Technical
Committee on dietary carbohydrates of
ILs I North America and I as Phi as the
international life sciences issue sounds
pretty legit right so it's members
include coca-cola Hershey Company Pepsi
company and Red Bull and a bunch of
others folks looking out for your best
interest that should go okay okay we're
problem if that was the only you just
you claimed all this recent study and I
honestly again no disrespect you're busy
with lots of other things you run a
successful business consulting people
selling stuff I get you don't have the
time you you weren't able to read a
basic forest plot to look at statistical
significance and competent intervals
okay I just don't think that the you're
the one to interpret the data so the
reason you don't have a you you haven't
seen the hundreds of really respected
scientists that have come out saying
that this new trekked study and by the
way there's an investigation into the
annals of internal medicine because of
this for accepting this stuff from
neuter X but if you're going to accept
the meta-analysis on red meat and on
processed meat for cancer then you've
also got to accept the 2017 studies
meta-analysis if you accept the source
if you accept the source the only
meta-analysis that showed no association
between red meat and heart disease or a
cancer that would be first I'm talking
about the one that you cited you may
doubt nurses like okay say second of all
I am pointed out the funding industry
funded research is four to eight times
more likely right yeah and going back to
that dairy one by the way do you know
that when they did their meta-analysis
they they doubled and tripled and
quadrupled up because when they looked
at when the the meta-analysis that
analyzed the meta analyses the multimers
has included the studies multiple times
you see I'm saying yeah because they
took it into account each time and so
when the industry floods the scientific
research with their funded studies again
if they find a study doesn't study
includes
the same conclusion adding those on as
if it's an additional studies that were
saying no it's so look if your industry
fund studies and an only decide if
you're an indie Fitness tree or dairy
industry are you going to put out
studies that aren't in your favor no
right and you also you don't have to you
spin it and so what you do is you want
to make beef look better if you want to
exaggerate that look okay or if you want
to make cholesterol okay you can you
know you can switch things around the
study to make it look good if you want
to look at eggs and for example and I
don't want to get like it continued with
free a debate about cholesterol and
saturated fat but if you if you give if
you go from ten eggs a week to twelve
eggs a week it doesn't raise your serum
cholesterol so that's how they did the
studies but if you go from no eggs a
week to one egg a week it does increase
your because there's something called
the cholesterol plateau so what the
industry does is it tricks you it does
I'm but then when you look at eggs and
outcomes like cardiovascular disease you
don't see what you do I was just making
a point that industry-funded studies
sway the results of the meta-analysis
right that's I think that's fair and
it's done with the sugar industry and
it's done with it was done with tobacco
and again I'm not comparing the the
amount of increased risk of cancer from
died that was never claimed that was
made it was the PlayBook that is used by
the drug industry by the meat industry
by the sugar you know by the sugar
industry by the dairy industry so even
though your film came out of these
studies came out right before you film
it's kind of proving your point that
this same company that tried to
exonerate the sugar industry is also if
you're gonna accept that you're gonna
cite that as evidence and they're gonna
cite that fact the reason I think
because what you said you're so busy on
many other things is I just don't think
that your fingers on the devil's not the
only study no I know it's not I know
there's other meta analyses 2010 15 we
can look at them you know if let's do
that okay let's look at those studies so
but I don't you know they're including
studies that are funded by industry and
so unless you can pass those out and say
is that really saying we can't rely on
any study no I didn't say that strong no
I said that I said that that you would
really need to look at the way in which
a study is designed to see if it was
viable and you also have to replicate
studies you know it like studies have to
be replicated and so what I'm saying is
so they can't just finish the last point
now like as sure as many studies as you
want because again you can show us many
studies you want you can't prove that
you're not hand picking them to suit
your bias you are the one that quoted
this study it shows that your fingers
not on the pulse because hundreds of
like top scientists have written letters
or joined in the same letter to the Al's
Internal Medicine asking for those
studies to be retracted and there's now
an investigation into the annals of
internal medicine yet you are silent
solution it doesn't prove nothing as I
was aware of that controversy and I'm
you can read for splice the controversy
is not surprising if red meat has been
demonized for as long as it has been and
then a study comes out which exonerates
it it would be entirely expected that
there would be controversy so and do you
know who that study was funded by can
you just put up slide 93 just there's
just to show that any rate so just it's
not just me saying this I mean the you
know the scientists who try to meet
guidelines didn't report past food as
retie so that because remember most
people are listening scientists who
discredited meet guidelines didn't
report pass food industry ties the lead
researcher Bradley C Johnston said he
was not required to report his past
relationship with a powerful industry
trade group under what that trade group
is but if we scroll down I didn't tell
you in the first one the sugar one it
was that Pepsi and all this stuff
although they make it they make a non
profit with a fancy sounding name right
and then they back it all with industry
funding same with the the meat study
that that's why I don't understand why
he'd use it if you were being objective
are you saying all these are the other
studies but why name this one as though
it's got validity because so do you feel
like they cut they concocted this study
and released it right before your film I
think it's likely that it was tied into
the delay but it doesn't matter whether
it is I'm showing that to to to present
that study as evidence
when the consensus of the scientific
researchers is against that study that
is calling for an investigation that has
asked for it to be retracted the
co-author of the paper who's part of the
leadership team at nutria Rex
he's the van Chancellor of Dean and
agriculture and life sciences at Texas
A&M right Texas A&M is partnered with
the beef checkoff program right and as
part of neighbors and this is also
discussed in the New York Times slide 94
and there's actually there goes a lot
deeper than that it actually goes back
to Brazilian government but let you
slide 94 by the side of 94 is just
closing about research groups at
discounted risks of red meat has ties to
program partly backed by beef industry
so I know right so this doesn't
necessarily mean what they're saying is
incorrect and this is where it gets
slippery right because if they found
things that happen to be correct and
they release it but they release it from
a shitty company that has said things
it's a [ __ ] should've chose it and
picked which studies and analyses who
because you've had plenty of times just
explain this yeah to get to your point
Chris you agree with the founding with
the the conclusion of that study and you
think that the evidence points of
there's many studies that point to the
idea that red meat is not in fact the
culprit and the culprit is when you're
looking at these epidemiology studies
that you're looking at the overall diet
of these people and asking them do they
eat meat you're not asked him what is
the quality of the food they eat yeah so
I agree that conflicts of interests are
a problem and I and you know that the
editorial that was published in Annals
alongside of this study said this is
sure to be controversial but it's based
on the most comprehensive review of the
evidence to date because that review is
inclusive those who seek to dispute it
will be hard-pressed to find appropriate
evidence so analyses had studies
covering millions of participants over
34 years there are several other
medicine analyses that have been done
over the past few years so I don't know
the best way to show these because I've
got him in at Google
so 2017 let's see if I can give you the
title team you can google it or
something contemporary review of the
relationship between red meat
consumption and cardiovascular risk
quote from that study the review
concluded quote recent findings
demonstrated that despite the presence
of heme iron and carnitine red meat does
not significantly increase
cardiovascular risk when it is assumed
and recommended doses you have 2014
meta-analysis of thirteen studies again
these are this one Jamie is called
association between total processed red
and white meat consumption all cause
cardiovascular disease heart disease
mortality and this is a good example of
what you were just saying Joe
there was a slight increased association
between red meat consumption and
cardiovascular mortality and then at the
end no no significant associations
because observed between any type of
meat and and heart disease mortality
results of the present meta-analysis
indicate that processed meat consumption
could increase mortality these results
should be interpreted with caution due
the high heterogeneity observed in most
of the analyses as well as the
possibility of residual confounding
meaning healthy user bias Lippe in a
meta-analysis of eleven studies of red
meat consumption and heart disease
concluded the quote the current
literature data does not support the
existence of a clear relationship
between a large intake of red meat an
increased risk of myocardial ischemia
and then this is one of the largest that
was done let me give you the title of
this Jamie red and processed meat
consumption and risk of incident
coronary heart disease that should bring
it up that's by Misha at all conclusion
consumption of processed meat but not
red meat is associated with higher
incidence of heart disease and diabetes
these you know so there's a bunch of
meta analyses that have been done over
the years that reached the same
conclusion and we could you know look at
the same same this is for heart disease
but there are also some for cancer so
it's not just that study there are many
others right as well on the other side
so you can present studies here so the
people that's true there are analyses on
the other side in present you can
present the data to the people listening
and it appears like the proponent
sentence is that but your guidelines for
diet they're not in alignment for
saturated fat they're not in diet for
cholesterol they're not in diet for the
amount of carbohydrates for normal
people they're not in line with the
consensus for carbohydrates I've said a
range of carbohydrates could be a
probably all I'm saying is you are not
in alignment with the scientific
consensus and you claim that we cherry
picked in the film right but you
handpick studies to back up your bias
not to mention that we've pointed out
that the studies in those meta analyses
some of them are heavily funded by
industry not saying you should throw all
those out but you don't have the
wherewithal to assess the studies in the
meta-analysis because you point out
yourself that you can't even read a
forest plot so he reads conclusions
right
he reads conclusions in writing but has
not looked at the actual data so you
haven't been able to establish when I
was like spent the first thousand hours
I would look at the whole paper and then
I would look at each author and I would
dig into each author to see where their
funding was from and I'm telling you
that the industry is funding studies to
sway things in their favor and you point
the shows that you don't have your
fingers no doubt about that yeah why why
didn't you point to those last time you
why did you point to an industry funded
study
everyone else before why why point out
in the new trek study you know when it
was clearly invalid the scientists way
way way not clearly invalid
it wasn't representative of the
scientific evidence they hand-picked the
studies that were including they used
the polemic they used the grade method
you know what the grade method idea okay
and it was and you think that's
appropriate for assessing food rather
than for some nutrition organizations
including well very few it's not the
scientific consensus so what is the
National Academy of Johnny just
basically use the methodology that
wasn't appropriate for looking at what
they were looking at it's just the same
with the Siri Torino and the Chowdhury
studies they the the the the what they
were looking for could never have been
found the association between saturated
fat and cholesterol levels it could
never been found based on the
methodologies that are used
[Applause]